hi today I would talk about antibody
structure and function our body produce
antibodies against any external antigen
so let's just look at where does
antibody come from and what is the
structure of it and how does an antibody
functions and what is the use of
antibody ei kabah at 1930 nineteen and
wonderful experiment when they have
injected the rabbit with over albumin
then they extracted the blood from
crappy centrifuge state as a result they
could get the pellet out of it they
could get the pennant of clumped RBC's
and WBC's and whatever is rest is the
plasma is the serum so they took the
serum and ran it on a chip and after
that they found characteristics band
pattern and they have characterized
those band and named those bands as
alpha beta gamma etc now antibodies are
present in this gamma globulin fraction
of serum now antibody definitely binds
to antigen so let us just look at the
interaction between antigen and antibody
so antigen antibody binding it's not
ultra strong so there are no covalent
interaction between antigen and antibody
so there are non covalent interactions
between antigen and antibody which
includes first of all hydrogen bonds
ionic bonds hydrophobic interactions and
vanderwal interactions now here is an
antibody so if you look at it would say
there are two basic chains one is a
heavy chain which is heavier in
molecular weight roughly 50,000 KT or
50,000 patents and another is like a
light chain which is around 25,000 so
there are two basic kind of chain now in
each chain they
in each chain there is a variable region
which varies from antibody 20 body and
this variable region is true for both
heavy chain and light chain both the
light chain and heavy chain have has
this variable region other region in
both the light chain and in the heavy
chain or constant that means their
sequence and their functionality kind of
remains constant throughout multiple
species and different antibodies so now
antibodies could be broadly cucas
classified depending upon what type of
antigen do they hurt do they recognize
so anti-poaching antibodies may not be
recognizing the whole antigen it might
recognize a part of the antigen known as
the epitope for example this is the big
antigen whose part is recognized this by
this antibody now if this antibody is
recognizing only one particular type of
epitope then this antibody is known as
monochrome otherwise if that antibody
same antibody is recognizing multiple
different epitope of the same antigen
then it is known as polyclonal
antibodies now there could be of
different types of antibody and it
depends upon what type of light chain
and heavy chain does this antibody got
for example IgG got a high lambda heavy
chain and IG got a gamma heavy chain
whereas Kappa or lambda light chain
so using these subclasses of heavy chain
and light chain a whole antibody could
generate a lot of diversity so this is
how antibody diversity could one of the
way by which antibody diversity could be
generated now antibody are the receptors
for the b-cell now in that situation it
is known as membrane bound IgM or
membrane bound igt in that case you have
an antibody along with that
you have a IG alpha an IGBT domain which
has immune receptor tyrosine kinase
activity which give rise to further
further B cell signaling now B cells has
an antibody which is membrane bound upon
activation B cell sometimes can
transform into plasma cell or plasma
cells our secretory cells which secretes
antibody so definitely what is different
between a membrane mount and our
secretory antibody in a secretory
antibody you don't have the
transmembrane alpha helical domain which
tether is the antibody to the membrane
that is why secreted antibody could be
easily secreted now antibodies could be
digested by several enzymes and that can
produce several fragments for example if
you do a harsh digestion like pepsin
digestion
you only get a fragment which is known
as if a pea another fragment which is
known as fragment crystallizable FC
region it's totally gone
whereas pepperin digestion would produce
2a if every fragments and one FC
fragment whereas my digestion is like
beta mercaptoethanol reduction which
would reduce that disulfide bond would
produce two heavy chains and two light
chains now there are several different
antigens is there several different
antibodies for all the antigens are all
the antibodies that are produced against
different different antigens are totally
different or they are different into
some specific regions it turns out
there's specifically different in
specific regions otherwise the overall
structure of the antibody and overall
amino acid sequence is pretty similar it
has been seen that only three region in
the heavy chain and in the light chain
there is high variability of the amino
acids so which amino acid is present in
this region are highly variable so these
regions are known as hyper variable
loops in this antibody structure in this
heavy chain and this light chain you
see and hear only depicted here is the
heavy chain in the heavy chain you can
see there are three loops and these
loops are site for polymorphism and
there is a lot of diversity of amino
acids in these loops so these are known
as hyper variable loop and mostly these
hyper variable loops of heavy chain and
light chain create the antibody binding
groove of a antibody antigen binding
group groove of an antibody now what is
the function of antibodies
first of all antibody could give rise to
complement activation so antibodies bind
onto the surface antigens let's say of a
bacteria and they can bring in
complement proteins such as c1 Q and
thereby activating the whole complement
cascade and they are by optimizing and
killing the bacteria antibody can also
also bring about antibody dependent
cell-mediated cytotoxicity so antibody
could coat the surface antigens of a
bacteria or another pathogen so there
are many cells of our immune system
which has receptors against antibodies
MC region so these cells are used in the
field macrophages neutrophils NK cells
etc etc so all of these has one thing
common which is FC receptor FC receptor
bind to the FC region of the antibody
and thereby engaging all these immune
cells against these bacteria and thereby
killing the pathogen now also antibodies
specially IgE class of antibodies are
involved in allergic response now
marcelles like other cells also have FC
receptors which can bind to IgE antibody
and make the muscle are sensitized
myself and a sensitize mark cell where
encounters an allergen for the second
time it would t granulate and the
degranulation from the mast cell would
produce bunch of phenotypes like smooth
muscle contraction passo dilation
striction and glandular secretions
etcetera etcetera also antibodies are
heavily used in biomedical researchers
for example in Eliza antibodies are used
Western blotting immunofluorescence and
also in chromatin immunoprecipitation
all these processes involves usage of
antibodies not only these antibodies are
also used as medicines so one antibody
known as trust - Ximena which is sold
under the brand name of her captain is
used as a monoclonal antibody to treat
breast cancer now rituximab which is
another monoclonal antibody is used to
treat several autoimmune diseases and
also sometimes some certain types of
cancer another important antibody which
is used as an anti-allergic
agent or to bring down that color bring
down that allergic responses is known as
O'Malley zoo map now O'Malley's new map
binds to the FC region of the IgE
antibody now IgE antibody normally binds
to the master and help it's 2d granule
it and thereby producing a huge allergic
and inflammatory based response
now Hamas will do map actually bound
bind to the FC region of IgE preventing
it from binding to the mast cell and
thereby reducing the allergic
inflammation response so that was
overall about antibody structure
function and their utilities so if you
liked my video give it a quick thumbs up
please comment to give your suggestions
your suggestions would be very valuable
for me and please share the video among
your friends thank you